[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans sa hotte caddie avec notre invité
ce matin suzanne delaunay belleville
bonjour vous êtes psycho praticienne en
relation dead et praticienne en hypnose
ericksonienne alors on va devoir
expliquer quand même que notre propos ce
matin suzanne delaunay belleville et je
m'adresse la aux auditrices et auditeurs
n'est pas de faire du prosélytisme de
l'hypnose mais bien plutôt de faire
savoir d'informer celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent et nous regardent que ça
existe voilà que c'est une pratique une
technique parmi d'autres une pratique
thérapeutique
et si certains certaines veulent s'y
orienter bien pourquoi passer leur libre
arbitre mais voilà ici nous ne les hits
poussons pas particulièrement et puis
voilà et puis dire qu'on parle pas de
d'hypnose de spectacle un conte peut
voir dans certains films où certains
documentaires mais bien d'hypnose
thérapeutique outils de soins de
traitement
voilà cette introduction est en fait je
vais vous demander de nous expliquer ce
qu'est cette action cette activité de
psycho praticienne ben oui je vais
devoir expliquer ce que signifie ce mot
barbare puisque praticienne parce que le
terme psychothérapeute depuis 2010 est
devenu un titre est réservé donc le
psycho praticien est une personne qui
travaille dans le cadre de la
psychothérapie relation dead parce qu'il
s'agit justement de travailler de mettre
les personnes dans une relation de
confiance
et puis d utiliser ce qu'on appelle l'
écoute active donc écouter ces personnes
les accompagner vers un mieux-être parce
que nous faisons des thérapies bref ça
veut dire qu'on passe pas des années à
faire une thérapie
donc les séances ont des séances très
très bref donc c'est de la thérapie
brève voilà alors on vous a invité
évidemment dans le contexte particulier
puisque voici quasiment un an nous
sommes confrontés à ce contexte de crise
sanitaire qui a engendré
une crise sociale et économique aggravée
nous mêmes dans les médias jimmy ou moi
et d'autres sommes contraints de relayer
d actualité plutôt anxiogène et donc ce
climat amoral difficile et qui est
inédit
quels sont les effets que vous en avez
constaté justement au sein de la société
martiniquaise à partir de votre point de
vue professionnel de plus en plus de
l'anxiété mais je crois que les
dernières le les dernières actions que
nous avons vus ont montré que les
personnes pendant un certain temps et
est dans l'observation de ce qui
pourrait se passer les derniers vide et
nous ont montré que finalement les gens
avaient besoin de cette soupape qui leur
permettrait justement de faire ce qu'on
a l'habitude de faire ce que les êtres
humains ont besoin c'est à dire ces
échanges et c'est comment dire ces
informations anxiogène ont coupé les
personnes les unes des autres et les
gens ont besoin justement pour aller
mieux d'être ensemble de pouvoir se
donner une petite tape amicale ou encore
d'échanger avec les autres et donc mon
métier est de permettre aux personnes
justement de dépasser ce serait ce en
sachant que c'est plus les dommages
collatéraux dans notre société qui
interpelle les personnes que de la peur
d'attraper la maladie
alaska par exemple audit des dommages
collatéraux ben là perdent perte de son
emploi parce que nous avons j'ai
beaucoup de personnes notamment des
femmes qui ont perdu leur emploi
certaines femmes c'était des balles
était la seule à en fait les familles
monoparentales
elle est la seule à pouvoir s'occuper de
ses enfants elle perd le job qu'elle
avait moi j'ai je connais des proches
donc des jeunes qui devaient avoir un
cdi mais compte tenu de la de la
problématique a pas finalement à bas il
n'a pas eu le poste qu'il devait avoir
donc en fait les dommages collatéraux de
lakovic 19 c'est c'est phénoménal
le coût est beaucoup plus élevé que le
coût de la deauville d'elle-même et oui
ça a produit des formes d' accidents de
la vie finalement on en a de plus en
plus parce que celui qui travaille n'est
pas sûr que demain il va pouvoir
travailler et c'est plutôt ça cette
anxiété là alors cela se traduit par
quel type de de signes de pato
j que je veux dire ben oui parce que
c'est ça c'est pas de petite déprime
comme ça qui arrive
l'agencé lightman physique c'est-à-dire
que les personnes
bon je prends par exemple l'impact du
port du masque je parle sans langue de
bois
l'impact du port du masque prolongé pour
les enfants donc nous avons des enfants
qui sont beaucoup plus fatigué quand ils
sortent de l'école nous avons des
parents qui perdent leurs cheveux des
personnes qui ont des réactions sur leur
peau parce qu'elles sont de plus en plus
stressés donc ça se fasse manifeste je
vais dire physiquement
alors évidemment on imagine que les
personnes qui étaient déjà fragilisée
avant la survenue de cette épidémie bien
sûr ont été touchés mais est-ce que
c'est finalement sinistrose
quand je disais voilà semaine simple
déprimé que ça peut être une forte
baisse de moral voire pour certains un
début de dépression 1
voilà donc est ce que cette sinistrose
ce catastrophisme aussi que ça peut
induire a pu gagner des personnes des
êtres qui étaient ou sont croyait
pourtant solide dans le monde d'avant
dans leur vie d'avant
ben justement le monde d'avant il est en
train de tomber parce que sans citer de
noms mais je connais des personnes qui
sont pourtant pour nous sans risque de
perdre quoi que ce soit qui se barricade
chez elle et qui ne veulent même pas que
leurs membres de leurs familles viennent
me voir parce que de toutes les façons
si vandorme apporté la maladie
et puis de toutes les façons comme je
serai malade donc en fait les personnes
sondées scénariste de l'asse doit forte
angoisse énorme et ça va même au delà de
ça la perspective de l'acquis cause
voilà dix ans de la cenco vie une phobie
la personne se coupe de sa famille si tu
viens il faut que tu as des chaussures
de ci de ça mais en fait c'est juste et
les personnes qui elles sont des gens
notamment dire vulnérables le sont qu'en
plus je prends un exemple simple une
personne âgée atteinte de la maladie
d'alzheimer mais pas une alzheimer forte
une personne qui a quand même déjà un
peu du mal à repérer les membres proches
de sa famille et que moi j'arrive avec
je le dis avec un masque jusque là elle
ne va pas me reconnaître
parce qu'en fait déjà ne reconnaît pas
et donc du coup c'est une personne qui
justement va être doublement enfermé
dans ce dans lequel elle se dote que
dans la maladie dans laquelle elle se
trouvait déjà il y à cet impact là et
puis nous avons des personnes qui se
retrouvent dans la situation comme je
disais de delà de la peur de demain 2 1
a peur de l'avenir
vous avez l'impression que comme dirait
sans nombre croissant ont finalement ça
reste stable et puis est ce que il ya un
message d'espoir à ce qu'il ya des gens
comme un qui sort de cette crise
angoisse pour ainsi dire ben en fait
cote
quand nous regardons ce qui a pu se
passer avant et après la période du
carnaval
je me rends compte que de plus en plus
les gens sont en train d'appréhender la
chose directement les gens parce que je
discute avec les gens
les personnes finalement ne sont pas
aussi comme je disais il ya eu ce temps
d'observation et seule période où les
gens se disent mais en fait nous avons
un pays magnifique
les gens vont à la plage les gens vont à
l'arrivée et je vais leur dire en fête
fête fête dont cela et puis fit au bo
case qui a fait naître un espoir
extraordinaire de se dire bah finalement
nous pouvons nous guérir nous avons des
choses chez nous et c'est ce peut-être
sur retour à nos fondamentaux
ce retour à qui nous sommes et puis de
notre magnifique pays seront différents
il nous reste peu de temps faut aller
vite je rappelle nous sommes dans face
aux cadets avec suzanne delaunay
belleville le psycho praticienne
praticienne en relation dead et
praticienne directionnelle on va en
venir mais en quoi votre activité
justement aux professionnels notamment
dans les relations dead pour être utile
à ces personnes qui a aidé le mot
relation dead
l'objectif c'est de mettre les personnes
ensemble autour de cercle de parole
autour de thématiques autour d'actions
en fait de psychologie positive parce
que l'objectif n'est pas d'aller vers ce
qui va mal mais de plutôt booster ce qui
va mieux
pour en revenir à l'hypnose les peuvent
naître un étang naturel du corps tous
les êtres humains
toutes les 90 minutes tombe en état
d'hypnose donc il s'agit d'augmenter
l'état pour permettre aux personnes
d'aller à l'intérieur d'elle-même
récupérer leurs ressources leurs
souvenirs l'incapacité vous pour
expliquer
on n'a pas le temps de rentrer dans les
détails techniques mais en fait quand
vous la pratiquez vous un diviser un
état de légères modifications de la
conscience dans lequel la personne peut
orienter son attention vers un but
spécifique c'est simple cela le principe
général c'est cela et les gens toujours
la vision de la personne en hypnose qui
dort on peut faire une séance d'hypnose
en marchant on peut la faire là avec dix
mille personnes tour sans que la
personne soit impactée on la vit tous
les jours je regarde mon film les gens
autour de moi me parle
j'entends ce qu'on me dit mais je suis
focalisé sur la démarche que je dois où
l'objectif que je dois atteindre voilà
et donc le patient on peut le dire comme
ça et soutenue par les paroles
persuasive évocatrice du praticien ou de
la praticienne
on va terminer pour dire que quelquefois
il ya quand même des effets secondaires
est ce qu'il ya des risques particuliers
alors plus peut-être qu'ils sont pas
liées forcément à la technique mais à
des personnes qui voudraient qui la
pratiquent récents être bien formés quoi
parce que là c'est quand même il ya une
formation pour ça on vise pas non non
non il y a ben justement il y a à faire
attention puisque cet état du corps il
faut pouvoir le reconnaître de savoir de
quoi il en retourne pour pouvoir calibré
et amener la personne vers là où elle
veut aller parce qu'en fait l'état
d'hypnose est un état dit perd
conscience
donc on parlait tout à l'heure de contre
indications mais ce sont essentiellement
les personnes ayant des troubles
dissociatifs les personnes qui sont déjà
dans la psychose comme le schizophrène
pour le solaire etc
ce sens là faux faux faux vous avez
prétentieusement faut vraiment être en
capacité de le faire correctement
merci suzanne delaunay belleville
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
jimmy tout à l'heure
dit que j'allais peut-être avoir une
séance gratuite je sais pas si oui c'est
ensuite si ça peut faire du bien moi je
ne ferais ça fait énormément de bien
merci bonne journée et bon week-end et
bon courage à huy dông khanh c'est vrai